[Music]
the game is changing
my job is to ensure the stability of uba
alex i need you to come back you are the
only thing that can save us
i don't think i've ever said that before
as a producer i'm curious if you know i
think you've mentioned it a little bit
the end game the trajectory of where
these characters will go over a number
of seasons i don't know how many seasons
nor do i want to know
any spoilers but do you know as a
producer have you mapped it out or is it
still kind of in flux like do you know
where alex levy will eventually end up
we don't it is in flux but what i'm
really hoping is that she goes into a
joyous
some sort of a
summer of love where you know it's it's
like
covet is going to be over
the war is over
people are going to be dancing in the
streets and there's going to be just
love in the air and levity because i
don't think
alex can take much more it was an
incredible performance and i felt like
it was maybe a terrible analogy but i
almost felt like your emotions were like
a sponge that was full of water it was
just rung out and rung out and rung out
and i know you've said that alex is very
different from you and i think you
mentioned that it was really hard this
season it was really emotionally
draining for you but what similarities
do you what do you find most akin
between yourself and alex or or what is
the biggest difference
well
the biggest difference is um alex
has
doesn't i have quite a
an ability to kind of harness emotions
and and put him in place and
it's she's a little
in the moment um
easily hysterical easily kind of
rattled
um but yet knows how to pull it together
when she has to and and
be presentable i'm personally not that
uh
you know i i
i've had i have communication skills
i've been to therapy
um i'm not a i don't lose my [ __ ]
so there's something actually fun about
about being able to
lose your
[ __ ] um it's it is very
it's it's fun it's been given permission
i should say because
i've watched many of an alex in my life
and it's very unsettling and i always
sort of take a moment and go um note to
self don't i don't want to be that ever
uh so
having seen those
different alex's throughout my my life
i kind of
just
pulled that out
wow
amazing performance um
speaking of so much of your
sort of going off what you're talking
about juliana's character in this season
laura peterson kind of feels like a
mentor she's so amazing by the way
so incredible
she kind of plays like a mentor to
reese's character bradley did you that's
that person for you did you have
somebody that mentored you that was your
sort of rock voice of reason anybody
that sort of guided you
i'd have to say shirley maclaine shirley
maclaine was my mom in a movie i did in
2000 something it was she played my
mother and she and i just she connected
to me i think
and i
we speak once a year um
she checks in on me and
you know always is is
cheering me on or so and supporting me
and giving me advice or talking to me
about you know she was a woman in
hollywood in a time where it was very
different she's been a she was a big she
is a big mentor to to me wow and now
working on a show with so many
incredible females females in the league
behind the camera no
so and not just because it's of the time
to have females
it's these are some of the most talented
people i've i've ever worked with
and it wasn't
they did not get the job because they
were a woman they got the job because
they were the
most
talented and most uh el you know they
they required they they did the they had
the chops
well said i completely agree whenever i
hear that term um i'm like we earned it
we have a right to be there and i love
that behind the scenes and in front of
the camera so many incredible females at
the top of their game
you're a dynamo out there i don't think
they're using you in the right way i
don't trust her she seems perfectly nice
oh god she bugs me
when i was watching your performance
being that this is what i do being that
these are the people that i aspire every
fiber of my being believed that you were
a news anchor that you were like a diane
sawyer you so embodied that essence so i
want to just ask you about crafting
laura i think maybe you said in another
interview you didn't use anybody
particularly as an inspiration but did
you and i know the costume designer said
that they used katherine hepburn as your
wardrobe inspiration so what did that
come into play
yeah well thank you first of all i
really appreciate that i did i sort of
used a
a mashup
of um
her stature
at uba is was like it's like diane
sawyer
um in that she has her own one-hour
weekly show she is a
respected news anchor and she's the one
they bring out to interview all the big
interviews to do all the big people
but i also felt like she had a lot of
grit a lot of rachel maddow grit to her
but also a real field journalist because
she
had been on a morning talk show
got fired
20 years before you meet her
and um and had to go through the fire to
get back to really why she loved
journalism to begin with and she comes
out of it
um at the top of her game and gets to do
what she really loves to do
which
ultimately isn't the morning show it's
the real news
um so i i
i have to tell you i just love this
character
i had a lot of fun playing
what an amazing addition to season two
um you know your character she kind of
plays like a mentor figure to bradley
i'm wondering if you had anybody like
that did you have a laura in your career
as you were coming up as you were moving
on any point in your career who sort of
helped mentor you or at least was an
inspiration to you
well sure many people i mean including
writers and directors as well but i can
tell you that you know when i was on er
i had never been on a tv show before
and i i really watched george was my
mentor i watched and listened and
learned from
him i i watched how he comported himself
on a set
which i think is the most important
um
you know the acting i felt confident in
when i was that young but the the
environment i did not feel confident in
and i needed help with that and i would
ask him his advice for literally
everything wow um before i would go on a
talk show i didn't know how to go on a
talk show i mean you know he he uh
helped guide me because i asked him
questions and i always say that to
younger actors i'm like you ask me
anything you want because i there's no
question that's stupid
wow um you mentioned people being at the
top of their game everybody on this show
is at the top of their game talk about
coming into a dynamic where it's female
producers female director female writer
you know female lead cast how does that
dynamic change does it change did it
feel different for you being on that in
that environment
well it felt different uh
you know it's a it's a it's a two answer
question just because we did it in the
middle of a pandemic
so i don't know how it was without the
masks and the shields and the protocols
that we had to take in order to do the
show
um but i can tell you
there is a difference first of all i've
never worked with so many women on a set
and when i say you know it's not just
the producers and the directors i'm
talking the crew
and it was thrilling
it was really thrilling
um
first ads
i had never once i had worked with a
female first ad but they are so few and
far between
that and so many female directors so
there was this real
um
i guess you know i don't want to take
away from men because i've worked with
unbelievable men too but when you see a
crew that's 50 50
you know male and female there's a
different dynamic on the set
there just is and it and it felt for me
very safe
um very embracing i felt safe to do my
best work and also when you're working
with great actors like that
you know you're only as good as they are
like you know it's like playing playing
a game when the tennis ball comes at you
from a great player you hit better you
just do that's just the nature of
science right so
and the writing if it's not on the page
it's not on the stage so it was this
confluence of
um an incredible female energy which i
really loved
um and also uh
a respect for the work we were doing
that was you know i went into it sort of
already knowing oh this is already
this is already going it's not on my
shoulders i get to just come in and play
because
i could see how much stress reese was
under
you know when you're producing and also
number one on the call sheet and worried
about everyone that's it's a lot i've
been there i've done that it was so nice
for me to just go in and
it's much play early in the game
i bet i thought i'd ask you just the
same
what are you doing
[Music]
first of all i
they they seem to love a good song and
dance on this show and this week you and
rhys
have a little singing and dancing number
little jazz hands happening now i
thought this was your actual audition
tape and you danced with your mama
and sent that in so break that down for
me it was on the way to your sister's
wedding or something
yeah so it was my my my younger sister's
wedding weekend
and i got an email from my agent and he
said listen man i think you'd be perfect
for this role you don't really have to
act you've already played a fake tv
anchor just
just do it again it's the morning show
and i'm like oh wow i love the show like
i genuinely love the show
and he goes you have to do a song and
dance number can you sing and can you
dance i go i can try to sing i can try
to dance
and then i realized i was like wait a
second every morning news anchor like is
michael strahan a good dancer is he good
at singing
i mean he's a good
singer and dancer under the context of
morning news anchors and so i realized
it really yeah this could be really
kitschy and campy and so i brought my
mom in my wife refused to do the lines
with me my mom my mom loves being on
camera so i did the lines with my mom
and we did the song and dance number
together
and they didn't they didn't they had us
do baby it's cold outside which my mom
is not familiar with that song so me and
my mom saying baby it's cold outside and
then we sent it in and apparently they
really liked it you nailed it and i
heard they want to hire your mom now but
my mom really wants to join sag-aftra so
she should after after that so
she loves the idea of residuals she
would love the free healthcare like oh
man
oh my gosh
so now i'm gonna put you on the spot
who's the better dancer reese or your
mom
oh my mom
oh wow my mom's pretty uh she's pretty
solid i mean what are we talking about
we're talking about current sema minhash
or peak like when when sema minhajj was
reese's age
um let's take her at her peek the signal
she is still at her peak i'm sorry i'm
saying steven may not just still at her
peak but i would say i would say um yeah
my mom all day she's great
oh my god i love sema all day i take
sema all day you you went you went full
in okay so you mentioned it a little bit
but
i mean you might have been offended if
you didn't get this role you are the
host with the most you've hosted the
white house correspondents dinner it
doesn't get higher than that you have
your own you have all this so did did
you walk in and were you like i got this
three two one good evening everybody or
were you like did you bring a different
energy to it did it go hand in hand did
it feel very different yeah there was
there was times where where we were
reading the prompter and we had to go to
camera one and reprompt her and i was
like oh man i got this i've been doing
this since the daily show like you guys
have no idea i've been doing this since
2014. keep up billy crud up like yeah i
was i was really
that's where i could turn my my swagger
on a little bit and then when i was
doing the dramatic scenes i was like
okay billy give me some advice
i love it oh my gosh getting advice from
his him is amazing so i'm gonna have go
a little i think the word would be meta
for this sure you on your own talk show
could interview any morning show
character if we're gonna sort of go that
direction oh
okay
okay who would you interview any morning
show character which character would it
be
um i feel like corey would be a great
character because
um
he is a sociopath and that would i mean
any time any time you get a sociopath in
the chair to interview uh it's it's it's
it's you know it's electric it's like oh
man i i feel i feel senator vibes it's
really good i know chris rock was an
inspiration to you to get into stand up
who was your dramatic inspiration now
that you're on a drama who's oh
res ahmed rizz ahmed gave me so much
advice
while i was filming and while i was
preparing for the role so shout out to
riz rizz is great and he's like he's
like my big bro and he gave me so much
advice and he's incredible
[Music]
i'm your boss i'm gonna make sure it
works out oh you're my boss i thought
you were my friend i'm on your side so
first of all i just wanted to say that i
think corey ellison is one of the
greatest characters in television
history i'm quoting him all of the time
uh congratulations on your success with
the role and the emmy and all of that
even though it's like however many
months later um one of my favorite
things about corey is watching his
cheshire cat grin when everybody else in
the room is thinks they got the worst
news and he got the best news
just wanted
the one-liners that come out of you
they're so unconventional are you just
are you bringing like a cheshire cat as
an actor and do you ever watch it back
and go that was good that was good
it's not typically the way that i
respond to my own work um
and uh it's mostly televisions out the
window um the
the there there is something about what
carrie wrote
that
it does fill me with a sense of glee in
reading it and playing it
only in so far as
that character seems so wildly different
than anything i've ever experienced that
i start to
get excited at the potential of
imagining somebody who could talk like
that who actually thinks like that who
could actually express themselves in
that way under those circumstances to me
so though i think that's part of the
cheshire cat uh part of it that
you mentioned which is
he's holding on to some secret and i've
designed myself what that secret could
or couldn't be but i think it mostly has
to do
with um
he has no fear of failure and he has
total confidence in his ability to
manage any possible situation whether
that's living on a futon and coaching um
high school baseball or uh running a a
network and living in
um a penthouse an extremely expensive
manhattan hotel
those are the same for him he's a kind
of monk in that way he just enjoys the
experience of living that leads me you
totally led me in when you said the word
secrets into my next question because in
this
season alex levy kind of has a memoir
there's a lot of books floating around
this season if cory was to have a memoir
that he wrote about himself
based on sort of the backstory you've
created for your character what
bombshell revelation would we find out
about corey
if he wrote a memoir
i suspect his memoir would take the form
of a series of haikus that they would be
as inscrutable as he is that he and and
perhaps there would be
12 of them for some
unknown mysterious reason and what you
would what what you would find is that
there were
elisonians following in his footpath
trying to decipher the haikus that he
had created to try to describe the kind
of person he was that's how ornate i
feel like carrie has made this guy
sorry
yeah no he's a true eccentric and uh
this is somebody who is
perhaps as inscrutable to himself as he
is to others and maybe it's his
awareness of that that brings him such
joy i think what we'll find in the
second season though is
carrie has uh turned the screws on him
and given him somebody to care for and
given him something to care for so what
happens to somebody who has nothing to
lose when they have something to lose
notre dame burn down australia burn down
the amazon stop
let's give the people some hope let's
give me some help did anything good
happen uh the u.s won the women's world
cup
jesus 2019 sucks
what actually occurred to me when i was
looking through your instagram and i did
go deep i read i saw an interview that
you did where you said that
you don't necessarily like to see any of
yourself in the characters that you
played and that's when i see
mia
i've worked on a lot of morning shows
i've been a guest on a lot of morning
shows news shows you so embody
i've i've worked with that woman so many
times so i just wanted to ask you about
sort of how you how you find her and
then how you found her again in season
two well i think i approach characters
from the emotional aspect first and you
know the characters written in their
reflection imagination of carrie aaron
and you know i am
such an advocate of whatever story she
wants to tell to you know and and it's
great to be in her reflection she's got
an awesome imagination and the spark of
it really is in that character and in
the work you do so
um you know that's that's my way in but
i i'm an actor that often likes to not
to say less right because i think that
as human beings we don't talk as much as
we do on television a lot of our
language is in our behavior right as
body language so that's part of my other
way in to embody the character is really
to to try to figure out what their
behavior is so those those are my ways
in what do you think mia's theme is for
season two just to give your fans a
little tease
the theme is how how do you handle power
you know she becomes the executive
producer of the morning show um chip is
out of the picture and the other guy is
out of the picture and she's given the
morning show at a time of extraordinary
transition and it really tests her medal
and so um i think the big thing for mia
is um vulnerability and power and
you know transparency how she handles
all the the many ways that that uh power
and challenge and transition come at her
i've been asking everybody in the cast
today to settle a debate is corey the
most evil person or is he the most
well-adjusted human on the planet
because he's the only person that
doesn't melt
no no cory's evil right to the car okay
so let's just get that straight
right down to his heart
you're the only person that actually
said that so thank you you're welcome
right down to right down to his uh
little bitty uh dried up beating heart
it's he's absolutely right to the chord
not a good person
in real life put your producer hat on
your tv producer hat on who would make
the best anchor well i i think that's
got to be nestor carbonell i think
that's got to be nestor he's got great
empathy and he's got a great
improvisational technique um but you
also take him pretty seriously when he
puts those you know big brown eyes it
looks like
they're the eyeliner and the mascara i
mean i mean what are you gonna do he's
so handsome you just want to look at him
all the time he's got to be nestor the
network doesn't think you have the it
factor we're looking to showcase some
other talent you know what the problem
with racism is you don't fix it by
pretending to want to fix it i'm so
sorry i'm going to do this to you but i
was such a lost fan
here we go if the characters of the
morning show were to crash on the island
who would do the best who would have a
meltdown who would flip out who would be
the ringleader oh my god that's a
tremendous question who who would flip
out i have a feeling alex wouldn't
handle it very well
i think i think bradley would would
would would do okay i think she'd handle
it i think she'd pivot uh okay right i
think i think yanko would be a disaster
i think
yeah i don't think he'd be good in that
setting although he is a bit of an
optimist maybe i don't know i don't know
um i think he'd lose it though to some
extent but but uh but i love
you put me there now uh and now you make
me want to go back too
we have to go back
well at least he could maybe do the
weather patterns and figure out how to
get you guys
how do we get off this island yes let's
time it with the weather yes for sure no
it would save me day he would drive
himself nuts yeah
i'm asking everybody in the cast today
to settle a debate for me is corey the
most evil person or is he the most well
adjusted person of all time you know
that is only one
question
so that's a phenomenal question you know
it's interesting i i don't necessarily
see him as as as as evil i mean he
definitely has
you know horrible tendencies he
definitely plays both sides of you know
the other of the fence there's no
question
but there's evil in every one of these
characters you know i mean every one of
them is capable of of some horrific
things
except i think yanko yanko's the only
one i think who i think he may be the
only one who's so somewhat redemptive of
the bunch maybe claire as well yanko and
claire ty ty seems to be a good sword
now there's a few of us there's a few of
us yeah i know
there's plenty of evil to go around yeah
no i'm i'm with you i'm with you because
i actually think that he's very well
adjusted he adapts very quickly but what
you're saying about yanko
he is
you play the best lovesick puppy
you just cannot get out of your own way
he is the nicest dude he just can't get
out of his own way so if you are able to
have a sit-down with yanko what advice
would you give him what would you tell
him
i mean i you know i tried to talk to
yanko and i tried to sort of work this
out with him because i was like dude
she's just destroying you
and and you're going down this very
destructive path with claire and now
with this whole thing where they're
trying to cancel you
i i i just tell him to to
he's a little naive he's more than just
a little naive and i think he expects
much more from humanity than humanity's
able to give him you know and he should
rely on individuals and not humanity for
for you know for a brighter future and i
think that's why he's so
he's so heartbroken he feels that
humanity has failed him you know at
every turn and he feels deeply
misunderstood and i would tell him bro
just stop trying so hard
right no i i absolutely can relate to
that character and just you sometimes
just can't get out of your own way um
alex's character writes a memoir this
season yes
other than alex because we sort of get a
glimpse into that which character's
memoir do you think would be the most
have explosive shocking revelations and
be the most fascinating read
um i think i think i think you nailed it
before i think corey would be
fascinating i think that would be a
great memoir
i think mitch's would be fascinating you
know and i and we get a sense of what
his memoir white might be because you
know we really delve into his
his thought process you know through
throughout the fallout from what he what
he was a part of
uh and and uh so i think his would be
interesting but i think corey's would be
super interesting i think it would be
great it's such a machiavellian
character it's fascinating what do you
think yanko's theme is this season like
if he had a theme what would it be just
to give him sort of a tease that
unfortunately perception is everything
you know
there will always be a part of me that
wants to be liked i never wanted to be
this person
first of all i just wanted to say who
knew that the most shocking revelation
of season two would be chip's real name
the use of
real name
and he seemed very irritated by it
yeah i think he likes being he likes
being chip no one no no he doesn't want
to go by that other thing so did you
ever have nicknames
uh i did i had one really terrible
nickname in uh
late middle school it was mark the shark
i achieved this nickname because
uh i went to see um who framed roger
rabbit with a lovely young girl named
shannon and it was going to be our first
makeout session
and
she reported back to everyone that i bit
her tongue in the makeout and so for
months in school i was known as mark the
shark oh my gosh when you subtract the
shark i had no idea that's where you
were going with it
oh well yep that's what i got yep well
it's okay that it didn't work out with
that lovely young lady because your real
life wife is on this season of the show
yes
i love watching your dynamics so if you
just want to maybe talk about how
awesome it was
well look you know my wife and i grew up
making films together our first film
that we ever made that was at sundance
was a movie called the puffy chair that
we starred in together we start in seven
seasons of the league together a tv show
on fx and so she's a filmmaker and actor
in her own right
um and you know while it was a a smaller
role for this season um we were lucky
that she was off of work during the
pandemic and we were able to bring her
on board it was great watching that
dynamic now let's talk about your tv
wife which is alex levy or at least
chip's tv wife i'm just gonna ask is he
in love with her or not
listen i i got my own secrets as to what
my motivations are and and sticking
around with that relationship and
receiving the emotional lashings that
chip tends to receive from her um but i
will say this i think those two are
are desperately in need of each other
and in their lives and neither one wants
to admit it they're they're codependent
but they're also pretty toxic to each
other um but there's a lot of love there
um and it's just one of the most fun
relationships i've ever gotten to play
on screen because um jen and i love each
other a lot personally and we can inject
a lot of that of that humor and that
love into that toxicity and it makes for
a great love hate dynamic oh you feel it
and you feel like in every moment it
feels like two people who have known
each other for a very long time
one of the fun things about watching
this just kind of an extension of what
you're talking about is characters
making terrible decisions and having
meltdowns so when you if you were to sit
chip down and give him some advice what
would you say to him
i would say chip there is a god-sized
hole in your chest
and your relationship with alex levy is
not going to fix this you're gonna have
to go to therapy and you're gonna have
to face yourself to figure out what's
going wrong to make yourself happy but
the truth is
that's not as fun television so i'm glad
he doesn't do it you're good i know as
an actor i'm sure it's a blast playing
the meltdowns okay so i'm asking
everybody in the cast today to settle a
debate
um is corey the most well-adjusted human
on the planet because he can adapt to
any situation he sees the best in every
situation he never has a meltdown or is
he evil which is it which side are you
on
so i think i think uh i think corey's
got a little bit of both in him um i
think that the fact that he is so able
to pivot in the moment doesn't
necessarily make him evil but i think
he's so cut off from his emotions and
he's so screwed up by his mother um that
it allows him to just be able to pivot
and be a little bit cold and callous but
i think beneath all that and once you
get past that is a very
ethical moral and loving dude um and i
cannot wait i hope we get 10 more
seasons so we can slowly scratch in and
and get to know that guy put your
producer hat on who would make the best
anchor in real life which of the which
which actor would make the best tv
anchor in real life desean terry i mean
he is unflappable he's super charming
and he loves talking to people all day
long takes great interest in anyone who
walks in the set infinitely better than
all of us
there is a pattern of behavior around
here that disadvantages the people of
color i just want to first of all jump
right in
settle a debate for me i'm asking a lot
of people in the cast today is corey the
most evil
person on earth or is he the most well
adjusted human on earth because he can
kind of pivot and shift like on a dime
uh i definitely don't think he's well
adjusted
um
no that's definitely not i i think he's
more on the line but i don't think he's
evil i don't think he's the most evil
person on earth i think he has such a
there's so many good sides to him but i
think what's so fascinating about all
our characters is that the characters
are so they have things about them that
are flawed they have things about them
that are noble i mean look at our
relationship with alex levy like i love
her and also i love to hate her and
sometimes i'm like i just hate you like
you are wrong look what she did to uh to
daniel
i know well that said i feel like this
season really i loved where your
character went this season but i feel
like it's the tip of the iceberg i'm
wondering for you as an actor where do
you hope that daniel goes like where
would you like to see him go in the
future well i think
it's really cool because uh you know
from season one to season two you know
daniel is definitely set up as our
underdog
um and so uh of course we love to root
for the for the underdogs i love to root
for the underdogs and so now that
well i can't jump huh
i almost did the spoiler uh
anyway so it's good you didn't say it
um i hope what we continue to see with
uh daniel is that daniel needs to figure
out and what and what daniel is already
doing by the way is that daniel is
determined and he is uh so effects on
confronting these problems and he's
trying new tactics as we see this season
um
and like one of my favorite moments in
the whole season was your new tactic
yeah so hopefully i think daniel
discovers even more and the wealth of
resource that is within him and that we
get to see him you know progress because
i think that that's what we all want we
want to see people like that move
forward and daniel has quite a journey
in front of him and it's exciting to
watch who do you think of the cast would
make the best anchor in real life
who would make the best anchor in
real
life
you know
i think
i think we're all good in different ways
but i have to say that you know i think
jen whenever i see her on the anchor
table there's this just so you know
she's america's sweetheart it's just
just natural
charm what i love about jen in her work
in general and i also like about in the
morning show is that jen knows how to
like even make her mistakes adorable
and so in morning tv where you know it's
all live i feel like seeing her you know
flub up or anything that she does would
be exciting and i and just find it
endearing i don't know how to make my
mistakes look as endearing as jen does
yet if she could just teach me that one
thing
during the show that would be greatly
appreciated i so thought you were going
to say yourself and i would have been
totally down for you saying yourself
because i know you said when you
auditioned for this in the first place
you were so like this is my guy this is
the character i'm going to get this role
like you felt very akin to him yeah i
don't like the job though
i don't like the the news anchor job
you don't want my job
no
um one of the great things about this
show is the meltdowns and the bad
decisions that these characters make if
you could sit and like when you read it
do you go yes terrible decisions i get
to act it or do you go oh no and like
what advice would you give daniel
first of all i love that you said that's
that's it that we see these characters
make bad decisions like daniel makes a
couple like oh daniel that's not the the
right thing to do
um the advice that i would give daniel
is it
and this is actually more a more sincere
somber moment but you know the advice
that i would give daniel is i would tell
daniel that you are enough
you are enough which is what i love
about daniel because he has this soft
core and we see him you know uh dealing
with this very very real problem um but
i think ultimately it's going to come to
that place where uh for this tremendous
fight he needs to live more in the
understanding that he he is enough
there's been a lot written about the
morning show and a lust for ratings that
made even the worst behavior permissible
do you feel that the important issues
have been addressed
i've now watched season two two times
wow and it just leaves me wanting more
so i wanted to ask you as a producer
do you know the trajectory i think jen's
talked about it a little bit you may
maybe have an overriding arc of where
it's gonna land at the end you know
what's gonna happen to these characters
even though you're working within actual
news stories and changing things as you
go within the seasons
yeah you know um the ending wasn't
really written until right before we
shot it and you know we knew what it was
going to be but it's different knowing
what it's going to be and then having it
be um so um
you know our whole journey uh on the
show was um you know
identity
um and who am i
and
uh
you know we deal with race
cancel culture sexuality
and by the end of the show
we're really you know
looking inside like who are we
because we've reached
you know we
we start the story
three months before
the big shutdown
and we asked those questions am i a good
person
um
you know alex's characters you know had
to
you know really work and you know with
the fallout of
um
uh
of staying relevant
you know and
bradley struggles with her relationship
with her
brother and laura and her family
and so
you know
who are they on a personal level who are
they on a
what is their public persona it's a real
road to discovery yeah and uh it was you
know these actors are so great they are
so extraordinary all of them
so
it's it's been a tremendous journey
um i know deshaun talked about the first
time he auditioned for you and said that
he felt seen and he felt that you really
saw him he locked eyes with you how do
you know without spoilers how do you
know with that an actor has that x
factor that it factor because you're
working with so many veterans on this
show but you're also working with some
newer actors that are auditioning for
you sure um i just knew we knew he was
just
he was just perfect
you know he is a he's an extraordinary
human being
and you know he's a great actor and he's
also a really good director you know i
went and saw a stage play he did he's
he's really
he's really
strong and you know when he walked in
the room he's got such a presence
and
he was authentic
and
he felt authentic and he felt
he felt like the guy yeah felt like the
guy who has to fight for everything you
know people of color
in
in our world have to fight harder than
anybody and and you know we wanted to
reflect that story in our newsroom
that you know if we're talking about
identity there's no talking about
identity without talking about racism in
in in
in our culture
you're just so caught up in ruling over
your rotten little fiefdom
the rest of the world they've moved to
the clouds and it is gorgeous up there
this is a battle for the soul of the
universe
so happy together
[Music]